is in a prison camp and in a legal limbo
she has been stripped of her british
citizenship and denied the chance to
fight her case in court
but with few options left she has told
us that she is now willing to face
british investigators and do her time in
a uk prison
if you if the british government changed
its mind
and reinstated your citizenship
and you were able to come home to the
united kingdom
what would you expect would happen
to go to prison
i guess yeah
but you
i don't put words in your mouth but you
think that would be
the right course of justice spending
time in prison in the uk rather than
spending time in prison in northeast
syria yeah
you deny
carrying out any violent acts
or any sort of acts of outright
terrorism yeah
do you feel that nonetheless
you have committed a crime to the extent
that you should serve time in a british
prison
i mean i feel like the only crime i
committed was coming here so i would be
willing to
go to prison for that but like for the
accusations made against me i'm just
gonna have to fight against them
and see what happens whether i win or
lose i will just have to sit
a sentence at some point in my life
the british government says that she's a
threat to national security
and many people agree
i mean i don't think i can reassure them
i think only the government can reassure
them and the only way for the government
to reassure them is if they come to see
me or if they take me back
and you know interrogate me
however long they want to interrogate me
you know they have people for this to
like detect liars
from the truth tellers you
know not hard to see who's lying and
who's not lying and who's consistent and
who's not consistent
bagon was 15 when she left east london
with two school friends to join islamic
state in syria
i don't think many people understand
what happened to you in the process
that meant that you you ended up in the
situation you were now in i think like a
lot a lot of teenage people there i was
at a vulnerable point in my life and it
was just easy for people to take
advantage of me
and make me do things that i would not
normally do if i wasn't so vulnerable
but this was online is it this yeah
online and between my circle of friends
who also left with me
did you go looking for it at all no
they kind of just they just find you
online
yeah
was it people you previously knew who
then took advantage of you all these new
people
both
people close to you yeah
my friends so
and what was the
what was the attraction coming syria
when you decided i mean tell me how it
happened you what do you do you sit down
one evening with your two friends and
say let's do this or what what what
literally happened
no i just slowly started becoming
practicing you know and i it opened
a doorway to like new people and a new
life that i thought i wanted and i
thought i
could fit into you know and i i didn't
fit into my community or my family so i
felt like i was going somewhere where i
could you know be accepted more for who
i was
and you were what were you promised
online what were you what were the
promises of coming here you know
paradise basically
and
hell on earth
what about the accusations that have
been levelled at you
about
your activity with islamic state they're
all completely false and have no basis
to them and i'm willing to fight them in
a court of law but i'm not being given
the chance
i mean you voluntarily chose with your
two friends to leave bethnal green yeah
but do you think you were groomed
beforehand of course yeah i would not
have
made such a big decision like that if it
was not for like weeks and weeks and
maybe even months and months of like
grooming
like it wasn't just a decision i made
very quickly it was like
a decision that i thought about for a
while
you were living
within this sort of
islamic state californt you can put it
like that
what did you see if you didn't if you
claimed that you didn't do anything
what were your experiences nonetheless
what did you see
what was your
time like
i mean i mostly stayed at home with my
husband and my kids i sometimes went to
go see my friends
obviously i was exposed to all the video
once i came into isis i was exposed to
all the videos and all the propaganda
that they were making and you know it
shocked me and it disgusted me
how far they would go what point what
point from arriving in syria yeah do you
think
i've made a massive mistake here the
second i crossed the border really and i
was in
the place for the woman getting checked
in
sardi javid who as home secretary
revoked begum citizenship has said that
if the british public knew what he did
they would make the same decision
but bagum says that she has never been
visited or questioned by a british
official
almost a third of her life has been
lived in syria and she's not leaving any
time soon
alice debunker sky news in north syria